[Música]
é certo que amanhã vão viajar poderão
ver imagens é que ocorrem na nossa
cabeça mas eu trocaria ensino mércia
será que você imaginar e muda totalmente
e isto é uma das grandes vantagens da
viagem
transformar um país como o irão o
paquistão ou afeganistão no qual nós
temos uma ideia pré-concebida daquilo
que é seu reinado que no caso do irã é
um dos países mais hospital gênesis na
face do planeta
e foi com base neste princípio
fundamental de que a viagem mais do que
um consumo dos destinos ou um
investimento em fazer deve ser também
uma ferramenta educativa e isso foi o
pilar que o vox fundação agência de
viagens que queria mudar o paradigma
hoje em dia uma equipa vasta pessoas
trabalha diariamente para proporcionar
não só as crianças o terreno mas também
as crianças aqui no cotidiano
e tudo começa com o várias pessoas a
conhecer o nosso mundo
nós queremos demonstrar que quanto mais
falamos do nosso planeta mais sabemos
sobre eu e estamos numa altura em que
isto é fundamental
quando ouvimos nas notícias que as
alterações climatéricas estão a fazer as
pessoas gostarem do clima jaru o que
imagina que você tem na cabeça o que é
que isso custe plata o quão da nossa
incapacidade para nos conectarmos do
ponto de vista emocional com esse sítio
está entre de planejamento nos
preocuparmos e de verdadeiramente nos
protegermos estamos numa altura em que a
ignorância política geopolítica não está
cada vez mais a dividir é e nós vemos
isso a mostrar por todo lado é
importante que nós consigamos traçar
pontos emocionais
com os outros entre culturas só assim é
que nós podemos trazer elementos
compreender esta casa comum
compartilhamos que o nosso planeta
estamos numa altura em que somos
privados a fazer esforços grande estamos
perante um desafio bastante importantes
que é o desafio de produzir modos de
vida e proteger ecossistemas nós
próprios agora aqui em portugal diz boa
soma em lisboa e no porto temos a sentir
o peso do turismo e estamos a sentir
como é que o turismo molda o nosso
cotidiano e nos afeta como o triste
momento é nossa habitação como é que o
treinamento é nossa alimentação
e isso são coisas que nós enquanto
turistas
estamos a fazer há décadas fora
quando nós vamos para um estilo super
triste que seja coroado seja massa e
estamos a ter um comportamento de um
visitante simplesmente quero absorver o
que está na nossa frente que tirar a
fotografia é isso nós estamos agora
sentindo papel tão sentida pelos
turistas que vêm pra cá estão em frente
à torre dos clérigos estão na baixa do
porto e olham pra uma cidade que tal que
nós vimos aqui na previsão anterior
já começa a ser pouco por trans e é isso
que o papel que é o ato de viajar com
consciência que nós quando decidimos
investir dinheiro e tempo a sair da
nossa zona de conforto que tenham
propósitos que não seja só simplesmente
se manter mais um creme no passaporte
mas a viagem pode ser uma ferramenta
também aqui na nossa própria casa pode
ser um sítio em que nós conseguimos
partilhar histórias pode ser uma -
através da qual nós comunicamos e nem
todos nós temos a capacidade de poder
percorrer o mundo e observar
todas as maravilhas que eu tenho nos
oferecer
mas a viagem pode ser também uma forma
de espalhar esta mensagem e eu que nós
temos tentado fazer através de diversas
iniciativas é pôr as pessoas a olhar por
nós mundo através da viagem por olhar as
pessoas através de viagem para questões
programáticas que toma definir a nossa
selada o que para nós é uma empresa
privada gera desafios bastante complexo
onde para o nós ver com o proveito e
andré começa a nossa obrigação para com
um é o que nos traz provar isso é
interessante pensar como é que nós
privados também temos a obrigação de ser
giants mudança não podemos cometer isso
simplesmente os organismos públicos ou
para o estado e que nós próprios
quem tem o poder de participar de uma
organização privada seja gila ou o
conglomerado agora existe um poder para
criar uma lembrança e para nós tem sido
ao longo dos últimos 13 anos
uma grande concentração de quetta nas
nossas mãos criar efetivamente essa
mudança e nós aqui na zona do do porto
ou melhor em matosinhos
queremos criar uma fundação uma
organização sem fins lucrativos em que o
espaço físico em que nós queremos a
ponte entre aquilo que nós vemos lá fora
e aquilo que nós aprendemos neste
laboratório de trial que manifesta
nós temos utilizado conferências da
virtual livros
tudo aquilo que nós conseguimos manter o
nosso dispor para passar as mensagens
para passar aquilo que nós observamos
contamos lá fora eo nosso dever enquanto
empresa privada para usar o nosso
prefeito conforme a mudança também no
vôo é criar um fundo anual prevê
financiar projetos instrumentais que nos
possam trazer algo último ano
trabalhamos com o público é em duas
grandes reportagens é promover uma
exposição que neste momento em digressão
pela europa e eu queria também deixar
aqui a mensagem de que o nosso cotidiano
pós deve também promover esta mudança
social do que o nosso e havia se a gente
espera que a gente está a seis lados
estão da corporação que podemos sempre
incentivar é que possamos participar no
maior do mundo
[Aplausos]
ah